Das ist vielleicht der durchbruch auf der suche nach leben auf dem mars die nasa hat strukturen fotografiert die tatsächlich
Spuren von leben auf dem mars bedeuten könnten die
Hinterlassenschaften eines masters und wenn man sie hier auf der erde finden würde würde sie jeder genau als das als tierischen ursprungs
Deuten also was wann, wo wie ist die lage auf dem mars jetzt bei klick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja wir haben ja schon öfter über leben auf dem mars berichtet und die
möglichkeiten dass es tatsächlich zumindest in der vergangenheit möglich war immer wieder werden indizien gefunden überall
Im all werden hinweise darauf gefunden dass leben vielleicht nicht die ausnahme sondern der normalfall
Im weltall ist dann wäre der mars einer der top-kandidaten für leben und erst vor wenigen tagen hat der mars reconnaissance orbiter
Riesige mengen wasser entdeckt wir haben hier ja darüber berichtet aber was der mars rover curiosity am 15 dezember
Fotografieren hat das ist wirklich atemberaubend auf dieser aufnahme sind oben auf einem stein spuren zu sehen wie hier auf der erde ganz klar
lebewesen
Zugeordnet werden würden die übermittlung der daten vom mars zur erde dauert der etwas und auch die analyse nach
Wenigen tagen fand das team der choreo city diese spuren auf den fotos und war
Elektrisiert sofort schickten sie den rover zurück um die struktur näher zu untersuchen noch
untersuchen sie die fundstelle vollkommen ergebnisoffen doch jetzt ist schon klar diese fundstelle ist so oder so historisch das forschungsteam
forscher zunächst in richtung von geologischen erklärung die
wissenschaftliche gründlichkeit erfordert dieses vorgehen und bevor irgendjemand seine wissenschaftliche karriere
Beschädigt dadurch dass er spuren von leben meldet ist man
Da besonders vorsichtig als erstes berichtete der amerikanische journalist lena david über die entdeckung recherchierte weiter und befragte
Wissenschaftler zu dieser entdeckung einer war es schön war sawada
wissenschaftler vom mars science laboratory so der chor city projekttitel
Er sagte zulehner david über die möglichkeit dass es sich
Um versteinerungen handelt also spuren von leben wir schließen es nicht aus aber das wird sicher nicht unsere erste
interpretation sein und wenn einiges darauf hin deutet ist noch fraglich ob die instrumente des mars rover curiosity
Überhaupt ausreichen um das zu bestätigen also
Um leben zu bestätigen die neuesten fotos bestärken jedenfalls den eindruck des tierischen ursprungs sie sind rund ein bis zwei millimeter dick diese
strukturen und fünf millimeter lang wie die versteinerung der hinterlassenschaft eines warum sie auf der erde der astrobiologe barry die
gregorio von der university of buckingham diese strukturen gleichen lebensspuren aus dem ordovizium
Die ich selbst schon hier auf der erde untersuchen und fotografieren konnte noch sind das alles aber wirklich nur spekulation aber spricht schon
einiges dafür zunächst sind solche spuren hier auf der erde
In den allermeisten fällen tierischen ursprungs sie deuten auf eine bi turbo aktion durch lebewesen hin dass heißt
Sedimente wie zum beispiel sand werden durch würmer durchwühlt sie hinterlassen dabei
gänge füllen die sich wieder mit anderem material
das sich wieder verfestigt wird der sand dann weggeblasen
Dann, bleiben genau diese gebilde wie auf dem mars übrig es können aber auch
Gänge übrig bleiben je nachdem was nach dem durchwühlen passiert ist die
Ähnlichkeiten mit fossilien versteinerung also hier auf der erde ist jedenfalls frappierend und anders herum fragt sich barry di gregorio welcher
geologische vorgang überhaupt solche strukturen erzeugen könnte ja fraglich es bleibt also dabei der eindruck
Dass es micro fossilien tierischen ursprungs
Sein könnten drängt sich auf andere ideen gibt es noch gar nicht der mars bleibt auf jeden fall
So oder so eines der spannendsten themen zurzeit ich halte euch hier natürlich auf dem laufenden
Zur aktuellen entwicklung wenn er kein video dazu und auch zu allen an dem verpassen wollten dann wird mir hier ein abos auge
unvergesslich dem genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informieren hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
außerirdisches leben an viel mehr orten möglich ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran